you
hi everyone it's Jerry I'm on chest coms
tactics trainer and I am now recording
my voice I just worked through three
puzzles sharing my thoughts and I wasn't
recording my voice so I already know the
answers to each of these three problems
that I will be presenting to you in this
video and seeing if you can figure them
out I'll explain why the moves are
played but this is a little pop quiz for
you I feel two of these three at least
are quite instructive this being an
interesting one for sure
pretty rare puzzle to see one that is
strictly King and pawn so I'll throw it
at you with each of these three if you'd
like to this is a block to move and
problem one if you'd like to go ahead
pause the video see if you can find the
solution okay the best continuation for
black is h5 this is the only way forward
many ways a couple ways to go wrong but
this is the way you need to go you need
to activate your King on the King side a
couple faulty approaches is to think
that well I'm just going to erase over
here because he's going to attack my
pawn well you're not going to be
successful because eventually once white
acquires this position he has all day to
bounce back and forth with the King
black King unfortunately is stuck he
can't do that and continually defend the
pawn so eventually the tempi run out he
could push after white takes and black
recaptures king b7 in the king s to move
away from defense of the pawn
so that's not working a king move nor is
g5 working because of h5 and the king
site is shut down there's no way for the
king to make progress on this side of
the board so by elimination and maybe
that's how many of you got the answer to
this one you have to start with h5
white has to take because there's a
serious threat connected with h5
actually if white ignores this and
approaches the C pawn black plays g5 in
this creates a past H pond G takes H G
takes H and he's running and H takes G H
for same story their form on h5 white
has to take and now it's another moment
where you can easily go wrong and that
is to make this knee-jerk reaction this
knee-jerk recapture on H 5 this is going
nowhere for black the H pond can now not
be disruptive cannot be disrupted nor
can the e4 pawn so what that means is G
4G 5 and f5 will continually be under
White's control and of course we can't
make use of these two squares so there's
a little wall that's basically cutting
our King off from accessing the king's
side accessing the f3 pawn so what we
must play here as black is g5 h takes G
H takes G and this is the bulk of where
the calculation lies with this problem
you need to have seen this sequence of
pawn advances on the Kings side and then
it's a matter of counting counting how
many moves will it take before white
gets a queen the answer to that is 9 1 2
3 4 5 he needs to get out of the pawns
way 6 7 8 9 and 4 black it's taking 1 2
3 4 5
the king is already out of this pawns
way 6 7 8 9 so that said what will end
up happening is white will Queen first
black will queen on the very next move
and it's still a little bit of a fight
but this is the only way forward for
black let me just put the moves on the
board so you could see this final
position the all these moves by the way
when I initially went through the
problem played out just like this it
went it tested all these moves and once
we got to this position it said puzzle
was solved it still
little bit of a work a little bit of
work because you know this prawn could
be captured and you know why to stop
upon but this is the only way to try to
hold this to a drop is to start out with
that h5 move so interesting puzzle again
we don't have to see the King and pawn
stuff so often in a puzzle so didn't
want you to miss out on that one I
thought it was instructive puzzle - is
this one right here where it is white to
move if you'd like to go ahead pause the
video and see if you can come up with
the solution okay this one actually is a
mate into much less sophisticated than
the first one Queen c6 very common
tactical motif is one where the bishops
are both knifing into the King position
dark square Bishop has these two placing
a bishop on a six will be mate Queen c6
there's only one legal move and then we
give me so matin to four puzzle two and
one last one where we are yet again
playing as white if you'd like to and go
ahead pause the video see if you can
find the best continuation for white
okay the best move for white is Queen to
g2 not f3 maybe many of you were
thinking it's f3 it's not the case this
pin is the main idea we are attacking an
unprotected piece and we are in a
position to take the knight on our next
move if black defends the night
Queen takes our queen c6 we can take the
knight because in the end we have this
resource Knight d6 with the fork so that
is an important variation to be familiar
with also important is to know what to
do on f5
well the knight is pinned he's powerless
we would then jump into d6 that's a fork
and then we take the Queen why is it so
important and this is the I believe the
key to this puzzle is recognizing okay
go in for the pin recognize the follow
up of a fork on d6 but how exactly to
place our Queen 1 which square why
should it be g2 and not f3 f3 is not
good because of f5 black isn't going to
go Queen c6 because of that take the
knight Knight d6 but on f5 now once we
go in for this fork and then take the
Queen black doesn't have to take the
knight back we are susceptible to a fork
with Knight d2 so we have to be with
this puzzle a little bit delicate
recognize the resources that our
opponent has and play to g2 not this f3
square we need to anticipate what it is
black can be doing to us just as a nice
little rule having a piece position like
this opposite from the knight on the
same diagonal 1 square separating them
he takes many moves before he's even in
a position to attack our queen when
she's on f3 he's just one move away from
doing that ok well a little bit of a
change up here with this one these three
puzzles as usual feel free to share how
you did with these three in the comment
section below and as usual I hope you
got something out of it that's all for
now take care bye
you